estamos viviendo un repunte de la
extrema derecha en la recta final de
esta primera vuelta
buenas noches juanín gracias por la
invitación si hay un repunte de la
ultraderecha que era previsible que sí
que se veía venir digamos desde desde
todo el mandato de manuel marcan pero
que en las últimas semanas ha tenido
cierta dinámica digamos positiva para
este partido y entonces la ventaja que
tendría macro en la hipótesis de una
segunda vuelta contra marin depende la
otra derecha se está achicando entonces
ahí hay un riesgo de un cambio político
en francia se cree se quiere más que un
estado a pagando la factura del
escándalo de la consultora mckinsey
acusada de fraude fiscal y cuyos
servicios han sido contratados por el
actual gobierno francés
emanuel ma contenía el apodo del
presidente de los ricos desde el inicio
de su mandato y yo creo que ese
escándalo de mckinsey es como la última
el último evento en una serie de eventos
que demuestra que marco ha gobernado
digamos pensando en algunas categorías
de la población y no necesariamente en
para el interés general en el escándalo
de mack 15 se vio que más de 1000
millones de euros fueron pagados a una
empresa que ya está investigada porque
no paga impuestos en francia y es una
empresa una consultora que había ayudado
al candidato macro cuando era candidato
presidencial en la última elección
presidencial entonces ahí hay sospechas
fuertes de digamos de unas ventajas que
se le dieron a algunas empresas y
particularmente am a 15 y eso alimenta
nutre la
protesta digamos social y los proyectos
de la ultraderecha sobre otros
candidatos cree usted que antes de auge
del cual nos habla de la extrema derecha
ya tenemos que descartar cualquier
sorpresa del candidato de extrema
izquierda jean-luc mélenchon
de la sorpresa y llegué a la segunda
vuelta
bueno primero que todos los niños son de
extrema izquierda era del partido
socialista partido que ha gobernado
mucho en francia desde los años 80 y hoy
en día representa una alternativa de una
izquierda un poquito más radical que el
partido socialista pero tampoco de
ultraderecha y muchos más candidatos
hacia la izquierda de menos
está todavía lejos de the main event de
está lejos de clasificar sólo clasifican
dos para la segunda vuelta están lejos
de poder clasificar en este momento pero
si la dinámica ha sido positiva y hablar
estado muy activo en términos de eventos
de
apariciones en redes sociales en las
últimas semanas y yo creo que eso
todavía no se mide del todo en las
encuestas entonces puede que tenga una
votación un poquito más alta de lo que
se está previendo de ahí al llegar a ser
una vuelta hay muchas dudas todavía